[Musique]
Paul tout va bien je suis là je suis là
ça faisait longtemps que tuavais pas
fait un de tes cauchemars raconte-moi de
quoi tu
arrivé ce sont que des
fragment rien n'est
clair vous combattez lesonen depuis des
décennies
ma famille les combat depuis des
siècles ton sang à toi vient de duc et
de grande
maison ici on est tous
égau ce qu'on fait on le fait pour que
tous en
profite et bien j'aimerais beaucoup être
ton égal je te montrerai peut-être le
[Musique]
chemin
occupez-vous de ce prophète envoyer des
assassins il est
[Applaudissements]
fou je vois les avenirs possibles tous
en même temps et dans nombre d'entre eux
nos ennemis
s'imposent mais je vois un chemin il y a
une toute petite
brche
mon allégance c'est à vous que je l'ai
faite tu me crois au
moin c'est une forme de pouvoir que
notre monde n'a encore jamais connu le
pouvoir
ultime je veux que tu saches je
t'aimerai jusqu'à mon dernier souffle tu
ne me perdras jamais aussi longtemps que
tu resteras celui que tu es réfléchissez
à vos actions pour la trade
silence c'est pas cette prophétie qu'il
nous réduise en
[Musique]
esclavage tu ne peux même pas imaginer
ce qui
[Musique]
tat